we started getting some visitors from
every universe hello peter it's been
very nice to come back to something that
is familiar but at the same time
completely new you're not peter parker i
am so confused right now 20 years since
his green goblin
seventeen years since my first time as
doc what was your name again dr otto
octavius
seriously what's your actual name you
got another chance to stir some things
up
how you like the new new electro is like
the world did me wrong now i got this
energy i'm about to go get mine you're
not gonna take this away from me
picks up where he left off what have you
done with my machine he's looking for
revenge do you want to play games
the goblin believes in a world of losers
and winners power is all that matters
[Music]
it's a wonderful world to be in we're
having a lot of fun they're a danger to
our universe we need to send them back
looks like we got competition
i think people are gonna be really
surprised they're gonna marvel
[Music]
[Music]
you